The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I guess we'll get started.
Last time, we were talking
about auditory cortex,
and the tonotopic fields
in auditory cortex,
the non-tonotopic fields.
Any questions about that first
lecture on auditory cortex?
We're going to continue
on cortex today, and talk
about some areas of cortex in
a specialized mammal, the bat.
It's where a lot
of excellent work
has been done on auditory
cortex that really
shows-- very nicely--
how neurons respond,
at least, to the selective
stimuli that are emitted
and listened to by the bat.
So we'll be talking
about bat echolocation.
We'll start out by defining
the different groups of bats,
and talk about who
discovered bat echolocation.
The discovery was made
just a few miles from here.
We'll talk about what the
signals a bat's look like,
in terms of what they look
like on a spectrogram.
Then we'll talk about
the specializations
for processing the emitted
pulse and the return
echo in several bat
cortical fields.
In the second half
of today's lecture,
we'll be revisiting
speech sounds.
We had a little bit of
that at the very beginning
of my lectures.
We'll talk about
speech spectrograms.
And then we'll talk about
cortical processing of speech
and language, especially
in the human, where
we have a lot that is known
about processing of language.
OK.
So we'll start out
with bat echolocation.
These are some pretty
pictures of bats.
Oh, I also have
some announcements
now that everybody's here.
So, on Wednesday's class,
meet at the Massachusetts Eye
and Ear Infirmary, if
you haven't already
gotten an email.
So, for a lab tour, we meet at
the Massachusetts Eye and Ear
Infirmary.
And there are directions
to get there from here.
You just get on the Red Line,
going inbound, toward Boston.
Get off one stop later,
at the Charles stop.
And then you're going to the
Massachusetts Eye and Ear
Infirmary.
So a lot of people get
that confused, of course,
with the big behemoth right
next door , Mass General.
So Mass.
Eye and Ear's a
different building.
It's a different hospital.
But But it's clearly marked.
The directions are on the
website, so just follow them.
So the lab tour will be within
the regular class period,
so 2:35 to 4:00.
We're not going to go
beyond that because people
have commitments after that.
And we'll-- depending on
how many people show up,
it's likely we'll divide
into groups and cycle through
several demonstrations that I
have prepared for you there.
OK.
So questions about that?
So we meet at Mass.
Eye and Ear on Wednesday.
At that time, the
assignments are due.
So we talked a little bit about
the assignment a few weeks ago,
when we talked about
the Jeffers model.
And you can send me the
assignments by email
or give me a typed
printed version.
And the idea is that I'll
look them over and then
hand them back to you
at the review session.
And we'll talk about
the assignments ,
and what I consider
the right answers.
So we did a little switch
for the review sessions.
So we should put
this on the website,
if it isn't already there.
But next week, Monday, we have
two review sessions scheduled.
The one on Monday will
now be the one on vision.
And so Doctor Schiller is
going to come and review
the vision part of
the course on Monday.
And then I'll be back
a week from Wednesday.
And we'll do the
audition review.
And we'll return your
assignments then, ?
OK?
So that's what's
happening next week.
Any questions on that?
OK.
So here are the nice
pictures of bats.
They're beautiful animals.
They have specializations,
of course, for hearing.
They have large pinnae, right?
Much, much larger
than other animals,
especially for their size.
They have very small eyes.
And their visual systems
are not well developed.
They of course have wings.
So these are flying animals.
And many of them
have noseleaves.
So here's a nose
cartilage that's
very well developed because
these animals emit sound.
Their echolocation
pulse is emitted.
And some of the sound
comes out of the mouth.
But some of it comes
out of the nose.
And this noseleaf tends
to focus the sound forward
because that's where the bat
is interested at detecting
some kind of a target,
like the insect prey
that most of these bats eat.
So I should backtrack
and say that we're really
talking about three
types of bats.
We're talking about echolocating
bats, of which there
are two varieties that I'll
tell you about it in a minute.
And we're also not going to talk
about non-echolocating bats.
And sometimes, these
non-echolocating bats
are called fruit-eating bats.
They are also flying mammals.
But they have big eyes.
They have relatively
small pinnae.
And they navigate around
like birds and other mammals,
using their visual system.
So they don't echolocate.
So you have
non-echolocating bats
that we're not
going to talk about.
We have echolocating bats
that we will talk about.
It's starting to get confusing
with all these groups.
In fact, bats are a very
successful group of mammals.
Supposedly, there
are more species
of bats than all other
mammals combined.
It's and amazingly
successful group of mammals.
And mostly because
echolocation has opened up
a whole new vista for bats.
Not only can they fly around,
but they can do so at night--
in total darkness--
and find prey,
their targets, their insects.
So instead of
being fruit eating,
these echolocating
bats are carnivorous.
Most of them eat insects
that they catch on the wing.
So flying insects.
But there are
gleaning bats that eat
insects on the forest floor.
There are vampire bats
that cut little holes
in the top of mammals and lap
up the blood that comes out.
There are fish eating
bats that eat fish.
There are a whole
variety types of bats.
But most of them eat insects
that they catch on the wing.
And we'll have a
demonstration of that.
So these are insect
eating bats here.
This one I want to
point out its name for.
This one is called-- in the
middle left, right here--
megaderma lyra.
So mega means big.
Derma means skin, ?
right?
It's so named because
of it's big skin here.
And lyra refers to
lyrical, or musical,
or something that sings, OK?
So these bats are singing.
Let's look at the types
of singing that they do.
And this display
shows the two types
of signals that are
emitted by the two
big groups of echolocating bats.
The first I want to start
with is the simplest.
It's called an FM bat.
An FM-- you have
an FM radio that
stands for frequency
modulated, or Fm.
OK?
And in this graph of the FM
bat's echolocating signal--
this graph is called
a spectrogram--
and it plots the
frequency on the y-axis
and as a function of
time on the x-axis.
And this echolocating
pulse is the thing
that the bat is emitting.
It's producing and emitting.
And the reason it's
frequency modulated is it
starts at a high frequency
and modulates down
to a lower frequency.
And here's another one.
Now, if there's a
target out there,
some distance from the bat,
this pulse that goes out
will be reflected
off the target.
And then it will come back to
the bat in the form of an echo
sometime later.
OK?
So the bat-- in this
case the FM bat--
gets information, number
one, if there's an echo,
there's a target out there.
And number two, the time
between the pulse and the echo
is an indication of the distance
the target is from the bat,
right?
Because the sound has to go
from the bat, to the target,
and then from the
target back to the bat.
And we know that the
sound velocity in air
is about 340 meters per second.
So knowing that
velocity, and knowing
the time between the pulse and
the echo, we-- and the bat--
can get information
of how far away
the target is from the bat.
Now, a couple of things
I want to comment here
on this spectrogram.
Number one, the frequency axis.
You might not be able to see
it, but it starts at zero
and then quickly
jumps to 30 kilohertz.
And then there's
60, 90, and 120.
So those are very
high sound frequency.
And so, in the early days
and to a certain extent
still, those frequencies
would be called ultrasonic.
And there's no real
good reason for that,
except that we're humans.
And everything is important
with respect to humans.
And our upper limit of
frequency, as you well
know-- if you're a
very young human--
ends at about 20 kilohertz.
And most of us, who are in
our middle or older ages,
aren't hearing anything
above 10 kilohertz.
So all these frequencies
emitted by the bat,
and the echoes coming
back, are beyond the range
of human hearing.
And in that sense,
they're ultrasonic.
So you can't go out and say, oh.
I heard a bat, or
at least in terms
of the echolocating signals
that the bats are emitting.
There are some
sounds that bats emit
that are communication sounds.
And those are in
the human frequency
range to a certain extent.
But almost all the
echolocating signals
are well above the upper
limit of our hearing range.
Now, another thing that you
can see from this spectrogram
is that there's a big
delay between this pulse
and this echo, OK?
The target is pretty far away.
Generally, bats
head toward targets.
And this has been
shown many times
in behavioral experiments,
especially if they're hungry.
OK?
And as the bat gets closer
and closer to the target,
obviously the time between the
pulse and the returning echo
gets shorter.
And, as you can probably
see from this spectrogram,
there are a lot more
pulses emitted per time
when the bat gets
close to the target
because the bat is interested
in getting a lot of information
when it gets close.
Another reason that the bat
doesn't emit very many pulses
when it's far away
from the target
is, if you emitted a pulse
before the echo returned,
you could get confused
between the outgoing pulse
and the returning echo.
So typically, bats tend to
increase their pulse rate
a lot more as they get
closer to their target.
OK?
And I'm going to show you
a demonstration of that.
I'm sure we'll
convince you of that.
So this is the type of bat
we have here in New England.
Examples of this are a little
brown bat or the big brown bat.
And if anybody has seen
bats-- have you guys seen bats
flying around at night?
Yeah?
Where do you see them?
In your bedroom?
Underneath-- [LAUGHTER] it's
where I've seen some recently,
which is a little scary.
Well, this view graph
says it hunts in open air.
Where has anybody seen them?
I sometimes see them
if I'm out canoeing
on a lake at night,
or in the evening.
Any other places?
On golf courses, for example.
And those are all
sensible, if you will,
places for the bat to hunt
because they're very open
situations.
And there isn't a whole bunch
of clutter, if you will,
that will return
echoes to the bat.
If there's a moth or a
mosquito out there-- it
might be the only
thing out there
above the surface of
the lake, and that's
very interesting to the bat
because it has one target.
It doesn't have a million leaves
of the forest, if you will,
to get confused.
It gets one echo, it knows
there's one target out there.
It goes and swoops out there.
And it possibly eats the
target, if it's an insect.
OK.
Let me give you
some other examples
of some information on FM bats.
First, I want to
point your attention
to who discovered
echolocating bats.
And I have his book here.
This is Donald Griffin's book.
It's called Listening
In the Dark.
And I'll write his
name on the board.
And I'd like to do just a
short reading from his book.
Then I'll pass it around.
So this is the
section where he talks
about this discovery of
bats' ultrasonic sounds.
So he writes, "during my
undergraduate years at Harvard
College, when I was actively
engaged in banding bats
to study their
migration--" So bats here,
about this time of year, start
flying south like birds do.
He says, "I was familiar only
with the generally held view
that bats felt with their wings
the proximity of obstacles."
that was how people thought
they navigated around, by touch.
"Several friends suggested
that I experiment
with the ability of my
bats to avoid obstacles."
Blah, blah, blah.
"I decided that I should contact
a professor in the Harvard
physics department.
That was Professor GW Pierce,
inventor of the Pierce circuit
for the stabilization of
radio frequency oscillator.
Pierce had developed almost
the only apparatus then
in existence that could
detect and generate
a wide range of sounds
lying above the audio range.
That is from 20,000 to almost
100,000 cycles per second.
With some trepidation, I
approached Professor Pierce
in the winter of 1938
with the suggestion
that we use his apparatus
to listen to my bats.
I found him eager to
try the experiment,
particularly since
he was already
engaged in extensive studies
of the high frequency
sounds of insects.
When I first brought
a cage full of bats,
myotis lucifugus--" OK,
that's the little brown bat--
"to Pierce's lab
and held the cage
in front of the
parabolic horn, we
were surprised and delighted to
hear a medley of raucous noises
from the loudspeaker."
So Griffin, as an
undergraduate, discovered
that bats emitted
ultrasonic stimuli, OK?
And he went on to pursue a
lifetime of research on bats.
While he was still
an undergraduate,
he designed some
experiments to see
if the bats could use this
echolocation to avoid objects.
And so he took a room,
turned out all the lights
so the bats could
only use other senses.
And he noticed that
they would fly around.
And he didn't have a very
extensive equipment budget,
so for objects, he went to the
store that sold piano wire.
And he strung piano
wire from the ceiling
to the floor of the room.
And he let the bats fly around.
And he knew that if something
touched the piano wire,
he could hear a little
sound of the wire vibrating.
And he had to go
down in diameter,
to piano wire that was
the thickness of the width
of a human hair,
before the bats finally
started touching the wire.
They could detect objects
even sub-millimeter in size.
So their sense of echolocation
was really well developed,
and very good.
It could detect
very tiny targets.
So that was one of his first,
and foremost, experiments.
Now, I have some demonstrations.
And some of them are from
Griffin's original work.
And so, in these
demonstrations, you
have a movie of the bat flying.
And the target, this
time, is a small food item
that's thrown up.
I think it's a mealworm.
So the investigator
throws up the mealworm.
And the bat catches it.
And on the audio
part of the track,
you'll hear some popping.
And I think that's a stroboscope
that's illuminating the image.
You will also hear
a little chirp.
And they're pretty
high frequency.
But that is the bat
echolocating pulse going out.
It's detected by
microphone, and transformed
from the high frequencies
down into lower frequencies
in your audio range,
so you can hear it.
OK?
And notice that,
number one, when
the bat gets close to the
target, the chirps increase
in frequency.
And number two,
when the bat eats
the target, the
chirps stop, right?
Because unlike you or me,
they can't talk and eat
at the same time.
So those chirps are the
bat echolocating pulse.
Here's the bat.
Here's the target coming up.
In that case, as
sometimes happens,
the bat missed the target.
So it's falling away.
Here's the target coming up.
In this case, the bat caught
it in the tip of its wing.
And it brings the wing
in toward its mouth.
And it eats the target.
And it starts pulsing
again after it's
swallowed the target.
And there, I think it caught
it right in its mouth,
without having to use its wings.
OK.
So these are some other films
that I won't go through.
But they were some
experiments that Griffin
did, testing the ability of
bats-- and certain species--
to actually catch fish.
And he was mystified about
this because-- as we've
talked about--
sound and air, when
it comes to a fluid boundary,
mostly reflects off.
So it seemed unimaginable
that the bat echolocating
pulse could go under
the water and would
be reflected of the fish.
So what he figured out
later is that, when
there is a smooth
surface of the water,
the bats did not
seem interested.
But when the fish
came up and rippled
the surface of the water,
that was what the bats we're
actually detecting,
the little ripples
on the surface of the water--
just as you see them visually.
There's some videos of
bats catching fish here.
Bats hanging out.
Bats flying in rooms.
Sorry about that.
Now this last part of the demo
is from more modern experiments
in which the bat
approaches a target.
In this case, the target
is somewhere here.
And it's tethered.
The target is fixed.
This is a spectrogram of
the bat echolocating pulse.
And this is the bat
flying, in slow motion,
to catch the target.
And you can see the
tremendous increase
in pulse repetition rate.
As it eats the target,
it stops vocalizing.
And now it starts again.
And this'll be
repeated at least once.
So here's another run.
Here's the bat
spectrogram down here.
And here's the bat coming in.
Here is the target, right there.
I guess I'd better stop that.
OK.
And so that second demo is
from Doctor Cynthia Moss,
who used to be at Harvard.
And now she's at the
University of Maryland.
And she does extensive
work on bat echolocation.
And so I think it clearly
shows the increase
in pulse repetition rate as the
bat gets close to the target.
Any questions on that?
OK.
So those were all the first
kind of bat I talked about,
the FM bat.
And now, let's get into
the second group of bats.
And this group is
called CFFM bats.
OK.
And these are completely
different species of bats.
They are new world CFFM bats
and old world CFFM bats.
It probably has
evolved several times.
The echolocating pulse and
echo are completely different,
compared to the FM bat.
So in the case of the
mustache bat, which
is an example of CFFM bat,
this is the spectrogram.
Again, frequency on the
y-axis and time on the x-axis.
But in this case, instead of
the pulse sweeping downward,
or a frequency modulated
very downward-- almost
like a chirp-- instead, the
pulse is a constant frequency.
So the CF stands for
constant frequency.
That just means the
frequency is staying
constant as a function of time.
And that's this
flat section here.
In the case of bat sounds,
just like human speech sounds,
there are many harmonics.
There's the first harmonic.
That's called CF1.
There's the second harmonic,
an octave above, CF2.
There's a third harmonic, CF3.
And there's a fourth
harmonic, CF4.
And it's conventional on this
kind of spectrogram display
to illustrate the sounds
that have the most
energy with the
boldest marking here.
So CF2 is the one that has the
highest sound pressure level.
And so that's the darkest here.
These other ones, especially
CF1 and CF4, are lower in level.
They're not as intense.
And so they're not as
black on this display.
And in this display of the FM
bat, the pulse is very intense.
And the echo is, of
course, much reduced.
Echolocating pulses
can be 110 dB,
if you measure them
right at the bat's mouth.
They can be very intense.
And, of course, the bat
contracts its middle ear
muscles to prevent those
kinds of intense stimuli
from damaging its own ears.
And then it relaxes the
muscles when the echo comes by,
and its hearing is fine.
OK.
So at the end of the CF portion,
this echo-locating pulse.
There is a little FM sweep.
OK.
So you can appreciate,
maybe, that there's
an FM1, a little FM2
sweep, a little FM3
sweep, and a little Fm4 sweep.
And it's thought that this
bat uses the FM of the pulse,
and the FM of the
return echo, to get
a measure of the distance that
the target is from the bat.
OK.
It if comes back
in 10 milliseconds,
and you know the
sound of velocity
is 340 meters per second,
you can figure out
how close that is.
And this bat can
do that, as well.
Now, what's going on
with this CF part?
Well, as you can see
on the spectrogram,
the CF of the pulse
is not exactly
the same as the CF of the echo.
OK.
The echo has shifted up to be
a little higher in frequency
in each case.
Now, how can
frequencies be shifted?
Well, it has to do
with the Doppler shift.
OK.
So this is a shift in, in
this case, sound frequency.
But you can have a Doppler
shift for any kind of wave.
For example, you can have a
Doppler shift for light waves.
If you've studied
the Big Bang theory
of the origin of the universe,
there's a big explosion, right?
Everything exploded out and
is moving far away from us.
So you look at the light
coming from a star that's
moving away from you.
It's actually shifted a little
bit to longer wavelengths,
toward the more reddish
hues, because it's
moving away from you.
So Doppler shifts have to
do with wave sources that
are moving relative
to the receiver,
or the receiver moving
relative to the emitter.
Another example of a Doppler
shift, this time for sound,
would be if you were in the
grandstand of a race track,
and the race cars were
going around a big oval.
OK.
And you hear the sound
of their engines.
As the race car comes toward
you, along the straight away,
it sounds like it's
higher in pitch
because it's moving toward you.
As it passes you and then
starts to move away from you,
it sounds like it's
lower in pitch.
So the thing you'd
hear would be [BUZZING]
as each race car went by you.
So, as the race car is here, and
you're the observer listening
here, it emits-- let's
say-- a pulse of sound.
OK.
This might be the peak
of the wave front,
if it were just a
sinusoid, let's say.
Now, by the time a race
car coming toward you
has emitted the next peak,
the race car's actually moved.
OK.
So the peak is here.
And the next peak is emitted.
And it's very close together.
If the race car is
moving away from you,
it emits one peak of sound.
And then by the time it
emits the next peak of sound,
it's moved a little
away from you.
The peaks are farther apart.
And we know the sound source
that has a quick oscillation
sounds like a high frequency.
And the sound source that
has a very slow oscillation
sounds like a low frequency.
So Doppler shifts are
positive, higher frequencies
for objects making
sound moving toward you.
And Doppler shifts are low,
or negative, in frequency.
They make lower
frequencies if the object
is moving away from you.
It's just the physical
characteristics
of sound coupled with movement.
OK.
In the case of these positive
Doppler shifted echoes,
we know either that
the object that
has been reflecting the echo
is moving toward the bat
or, conversely, that
the bat has been flying
toward the object that
is emitting the echo.
So a positive
Doppler shift means
things are getting
closer together.
And a negative
Doppler shift would
be things are going
farther apart.
So not only does the
bat, from its FM sweep,
get an indication of how far
it is away from the target.
But by its Doppler
shifted CF part,
it gets an idea of the
relative motion of the target.
Why is that important?
These types of bats,
instead of hunting
in open air-- like
the FM bats we
have-- these are tropical bats.
And they hunt in
dense vegetation,
like the tropical rain forests.
And there are millions
of objects around.
There are leaves.
There's vines.
There's lots of clutter here.
What the bat is interested
in is not stationary clutter.
Presumably, things that are
Doppler shifted all the same.
But something that is
moving in all this clutter.
It's very interested
in moving objects
because that's a
life form, perhaps.
And just imagine the
kind of a Doppler shift
that would be made
by a moth, first
beating its wing toward
you, if you were the bat.
And then beating its wing
downward, and away, from you.
OK.
That's a very complicated
positive and negative Doppler
shift that the bat would
pick up on its return echo.
And that would be a very
interesting target to the bat.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And how do they
tell that the difference is
when they're moving versus
if the object is [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: They don't care.
All they care about is that
they might be getting thousands
of Doppler shifted echoes from
the targets in front of them.
Let's say they're flying toward
a whole bunch of tropical rain
forest vegetation.
There are going to be thousands
of positive Doppler shifted
echoes.
And then something is moving
away from them, or toward them,
faster than the background.
All they care is that.
It's Doppler shifted different
relative to the background.
They're just looking
for something special.
That is, something that's moving
relative to the background.
Any other questions on that?
So you can, of course,
design sonar systems.
Submarine sonar systems work by
sending out a pulse of sound,
and listening for the echo.
And most of the kinds
of sonar systems
that we have send out a
ping, which is a frequency
swept signal, and
listen for the echo.
Because it's mostly interested
in the distance from a target,
and whether there's
a target out there.
This is a very unusual type
of echolocation, or sonar,
if you will.
Now why am I bringing this up?
Well, it's very
interesting because the bat
gets two queues
instead of just one.
Also because a lot of work on
bat cortex has used CFFM bats.
And one of the most popular
has been the so-called mustache
bat, I believe because
it has a noseleaf that's
between its upper lip--
it looks like a mustache--
and its nostrils.
So it's called the mustache bat.
And a lot of this
work has been done
by a researcher, who is
still active, at Washington
University in Saint Louis.
And his name is Nobua Suga.
And he was the first,
really, to work successfully
on the bat auditory cortex.
A lot of his work comes from
the 1970s, '80s, and '90s.
And before I explain this
bottom part of this slide,
let me just go on and show
you the kinds of experiments
that Suga did.
And here's one from one of
his publications in the 1980s.
So Suga's work was innovative
because he played around--
well, first he rationalized, OK.
I could try any sound
system I'd like to.
I could try clicks.
I could try pure tones.
I could try noise.
I could try speech.
I could try-- but why don't
I try what the bat listens to
over and over?
It listens to a pulse.
And then a little
bit later, an echo.
And this turned out to be
a very, very wise choice,
as we'll see in a minute.
Secondly, about the
time of the 1970s
and '80s, speech
researchers in human speech
were using synthesized speech.
Of course, we all know what
synthesized speech is now.
But back then, it
was very novel.
And Suga says, well, I'm
going to use synthesized bat
echolocating calls.
And here is an example
of a synthesized pulse.
So this is for the mustache bat.
And this looks like CF1-FM1,
CF2-FM2, and CF3-FM3.
So he's just using
three harmonics.
So one thing about
synthesized calls
is you can do things like
dispense with one harmonic,
if you want to, easily take
it out, and put it an echo.
So here's a pulse.
And here's an echo.
It's a little bit
Doppler shifted.
You can look at the no response
to the pulse, and to the echo.
And this lower
trace is a histogram
from a single neuron
in the auditory cortex
of the echolocating bat to
a pulse, and to an echo.
There's not much response.
Suga found that when
you play a pulse
and, a short time later, an
echo, you get a huge response.
And that's what's
indicated here.
So this is the
pulse-echo combination.
And these are
synthesized stimuli.
And you can read in
the original paper,
it looks like it's
not given here,
exactly what the delay is
between the pulse and the echo.
But Suga tried various
pulse-echo delays.
And he found that cortical
neurons, in many cases,
were very sensitive
to the exact delay
between the pulse and the echo.
So they were, if you
will, delay tuned.
And that's indicated
here, in the first bullet.
"The neuron pictured above
responds little to--" blah,
blah, blah. "--pulse
of an echo alone.
But vigorously to a
pulse followed by an echo
at certain delay.
In this case, 9.3
milliseconds is
the best delay for this neuron."
So this is a delay tuned neuron.
Once Suga did recordings from
different parts of the bat
cortex, he found that the
best delay was actually
mapped along the
surface of the cortex.
So here is some of his
work from the 1990s,
showing you maps of best
delays, and other properties,
in the bat auditory cortex.
So here is a side view
of the bat cortex.
This is looking
at the left side.
This is the front, where
the olfactory areas are.
Way in the back would
be the occipital cortex.
And our old friend,
the auditory cortex,
is in the temporal region,
on the side of the brain,
just like it was in the cat.
And like it is in the human.
And here is A1.
And this rectangle
here is expanded here.
And some of Suga's
maps are shown.
This part right here--
the biggest part--
is cortical field A1, which,
as we've seen in other animals,
is the tonotopically
organized field.
And it's tonotopically
organized in this bat.
And these numbers and lines
are the ISO frequency laminae.
So remember, the
experiment here is
to go in and sample at a
specific place in the cortex,
and find the
characteristic frequency
for neurons in that column.
And then move the
electrode a little bit.
Do the same.
Get the tuning curve.
Get the CF for those neurons.
And so on and so forth.
And build up a map here.
So just like in the
cat, posterior areas
are tuned to low CF.
Low CFs in the bat
are 20 kilohertz.
We're dealing with very,
very high frequencies.
As you go more rostrally, the
CFs get increasingly high.
And at the very rostral end of
A1, the CF is 100 kilohertz.
Extremely high.
And everything looks
exactly like other mammals,
except for this huge area
right in the middle of A1.
And almost all of
the neurons here
are tuned to between
61 and 66 kilohertz.
And you should perk up
your ears a little bit
because that is where
the most intense harmonic
of echolocating pulse is,
right around 61 kilohertz.
And a lot of the Doppler
shifted echoes are just
going to be a little
bit above that.
If the bat is flying
toward the target,
this region goes up
then to 66 kilohertz.
So then there is an expanded
region of the A1 of the bat
that's tuned to a very important
frequency for the echolocating
signal.
And, at first, this was
called an acoustic fovea.
Because if you go down into
lower nuclei of the bat
pathway, and if you actually
go into the cochlea,
you find an expanded region
of the cochlea devoted
to these same frequencies.
That is, you go along
the basilar membrane,
starting at the
most apical regions,
and you march down them.
When you get to the
61 kilohertz place,
there's a lot of cochlea
devoted to processing that area.
And so the fovea,
the eyes, where
you have lots of receptor cells
packed in to a certain part.
And this is where you have a
lot of hair cells packed in,
or expanded region of
the basilar membrane,
where lots of hair
cells processing
this small range of frequencies.
So this is very much
different from other mammals.
And the cochlea of this CFFM
bat is also very different.
Now, we were talking
about delay to neurons.
And Suga found a very
interesting area near A1
in which there is a
mapping for best delay.
And that's indicated here.
And the best delays are marching
from short to longer best
delays, as these
arrows go along here.
Now they're marked
FM1, FM2, FM3.
So what does all that mean?
So Suga found that with his
synthesized pulses and echoes,
he could dissect this
rather complicated
pulse-echo constellation
into smaller parts.
And here's an example of
a stimulus where you have,
it looks like, CF2-FM2, CF3-FM3.
And you have the
echo for CF1-FM1,
and the echo for CF3-FM3.
And that hardly gave any
response to the neurons.
Here's an example where you
have only CF1-FM1 for the pulse,
and only CF2-FM2 for the echo.
And it gave a big response.
And you could do even more.
You can strip off
everything except the FM1
and the echo FM2.
And you get a big
response from the neuron.
So this type of
neuron, then, would
be called an FM1-FM2
best delay neuron.
FM1 is the pulse.
FM2 is the echo.
And with a certain
delay between those two,
you get as big a response as
with the whole constellation
of pulse and echo.
And those neurons were located
in this specific region, called
FM1-FM2.
And their delays were
mapped along this axis,
with delays going from
0.4 to 18 milliseconds.
And knowing the
velocity of sound,
you can convert that
to a target range
of between 7 and
310 centimeters.
That's how far the
target was from the bat
at that specific best delay.
Suga also found some
other best delay regions.
For example, FM2, FM3,
so on and so forth
in other adjacent
parts of cortex.
And this is really
beautiful work,
showing specializations for
cortical neuron response.
And for showing mappings
for those specializations
in the bat cortex.
We don't really have any data
anywhere near as beautiful
on non-echolocating mammalian
cortex that show specialization
for specific features of sound
stimuli as we do like this
in the bat cortex.
And this is really
beautiful work.
This is Nobel Prize
deserving work
because it really shows us
what this bat cortex is doing.
It's responding to specific
features of the pulse.
And the return echo delay
a specific delay later.
So it's very beautiful work.
Let me just mention
one other region here.
Suga showed nearby, a
region where the neurons are
specialized to
certain combinations
of the constant
frequency of the echo.
And then he showed
a Doppler shifted
constant [INAUDIBLE]
pulse and CF of the echo.
So this is the CFCF
region right over here.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: In the last diagram--
PROFESSOR: This one
or the one before?
AUDIENCE: This one right here.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: The last graph,
like the middle bottom.
PROFESSOR: This guy?
AUDIENCE: Why is that the
neuron is responding, like,
before the onset frequency?
PROFESSOR: I don't
know why that is.
There's some clue to that, as to
why this stimulus starts here.
I don't know.
I don't know the answer to that.
Let's see if it says
anything in the caption.
I don't know.
I don't know why that is.
Sorry.
I'll have to dig out the
paper and figure that out.
Any other questions?
So one thing that's gone
on after Sugo's early work
on these specializations
has asked the question,
is this really happening
in the auditory cortex?
Or is the cortex just
merely a reflection
of some beautiful processing at
a lower level of the pathway?
And to a certain extent,
best delay sensitivity
is found at lower levels.
For example, the
inferior colliculus
has some best
delay tuned neurons
in the echolocating bat.
So it probably has more
in the auditory cortex.
But they can arise at
the inferior colliculus.
OK.
So that's what I wanted to
say about bat echolocation.
And now I'm going to move on and
spend the last part of today's
class talking about
speech sounds.
So we had this particular
slide in an earlier lecture,
I think the very first
lecture that I gave,
talking about what
speech sounds are.
So speech sounds, obviously,
are formed in humans
by the vocal cords,
or vocal folds,
closing and opening during
airflow from the lungs
to the upper vocal tract.
And this closing and
opening of the glottis
gives rise to the
so-called glottal pulses.
When the vocal cords are closed,
there's no airflow coming out.
But when they open,
there's turbulent airflow
and it makes a sound.
So these are pulses.
And they have a whole bunch
of different frequencies.
So this is the wave form
as a function of time.
Sound pressure is
a function of time.
And this is the spectrum showing
the different frequencies
that are formed.
There's a whole bunch
of different frequencies
in your glottal pulses.
It's very complicated.
To form different
speech sounds, you
do things with your
upper vocal tract.
In this case of vowels,
you position the muscles
so that your upper vocal tract
forms filters that enhance
and decrease some of
these frequencies.
And after you apply the filter
function of the vocal tract
to this glottal pulse spectrum,
you get this type of spectrum
where there are certain peaks.
And in the production
of a vowel,
these peaks are at
different frequencies.
So, for this example,
the vowel "eh" in hit,
you have a very low peak, and
a couple of high peaks up here.
These pacer called formants.
And they're labeled by Fs.
So we went over this before.
So there's F1 here,
F2, and F3 here.
And certain cochlear implant
processors, of course.
Try to look at the
acoustic spectrum,
and pick off these formants.
And they present a lot
of electrical stimuli
to electrodes that correspond
to them in the cochlea.
This one we have a
lot of stimulation
at these low
frequency electrodes,
which would be apical
in the cochlear implant.
And then in the
intermediate electrodes,
they completely shut them
down, even if there's
a little bit of
background noise.
And then they would present a
lot of stimuli at the position
corresponding to F2 and F3.
And that's an effort to
decrease background noise, which
is always a big
problem in listening
to any kind of
acoustic wave form.
But especially if you
have a cochlear implant.
So this vowel, "ah,"
in the word "call"
has two formants very
low in frequency.
And one in the middle frequency.
It sounds very
different, of course.
And your vocal tract
position is very different.
And this volume, which is
"oo," as in the word cool,
has three fairly evenly
spaced formants here.
Your vocal tract is yet
in a different position.
And you interpret this
as yet a different vowel.
Now that's a display that's
not very conventional.
Much more conventional is to
look at a speech spectrogram.
So this is very similar
to what we've just
looked at for bat
echolocating pulses.
This spectrogram is a graph
on the y-axis of frequencies.
And now these are more
normal sonic, if you will,
frequencies.
These are well within the
human range, of course,
going from 0 to 7
kilohertz on this axis.
This is a time axis here.
And again, the higher
in level, the darker the
display in the spectrogram.
So there's some really
dark bands here.
And there's some very light
stuff here, and here, and here.
And this is the utterance-- "Joe
took father's shoe bench out."
OK, and that's what
the sound looks
like when you make
that utterance.
So the spectrogram plots the
frequencies of speech sounds
over time.
What we've talked
about-- up until now--
are voiced segments,
which are mostly vowels.
So in this utterance, you
have a bunch of vowels here.
Here's a nice one, "ah"
in the word father's.
And you can quite clearly
see there's a nice band here
that would be F1.
That would be about
at 500 kilohertz.
And F2 is about at 1 kilohertz.
F3 would be about
at 2 kilohertz.
And there's a fourth
formant about 3 kilohertz.
And that's the very beautiful
vowel, "ah" as in father.
Here's another one.
"Joe."
So "oh." "Oh" is a vowel
where, in this case,
there's a beautiful
stable formant here.
But here is a formant
that's transitioning
from higher frequency,
maybe about 1.5 kilohertz,
down to below 1 kilohertz.
So it's Joe.
And there's a
higher formant here.
OK.
So those are the vowels, or
the so-called voiced segments.
And voicing just
means that there's
a constant outflow of sound
coming through the vocal tract.
And you can make
these sounds forever.
You can say, ahhhhhhh.
And you can just keep
going if you want to.
Of course, you don't
in normal speech.
Now for consonants,
there are several types.
And these are generally
called unvoiced segments.
Mostly consonants are
intervals containing
bands of frequencies,
swept frequencies,
and silent intervals.
So for example, one
of the consonants
here is F in the word fathers.
And right before, at the
beginning of the sound F,
you go, which is
no sound, right?
You close your lips.
You keep sound from coming out.
And you finally
go, father, right?
And that's what's
happening right here.
So that's a stop consonant.
You stop the vocal tract
before you let it go.
And the vowel T, as in took,
is another stop consonant.
So you're not doing
anything at the beginning.
And finally, you go, took.
Right?
When you let go, and
emit the sound of took,
you have a very
complex frequency band.
That's generally
high frequencies.
2 kilohertz in this case,
up beyond 7 kilohertz.
There's that explosion
of sound right
at the beginning of the
consonant T, as and took.
OK.
Now there been a lot of
course studies on speech
coding in the auditory nerve
and the cochlear nucleus.
And one of the findings
shouldn't be too surprising
at all.
You have auditory nerve fibers
that have tuning curves, right?
We've been over tuning
curves many times before.
So tuning curve is a
graph of sound pressure
level for a response.
There's a sound frequency here.
And then a 1 kilohertz CF.
The CF for this tuning
curve would be 1 kilohertz,
let's say.
And a 10 kilohertz CF
might look like that.
OK.
So you can explore the responses
of 1 kilohertz auditory nerve
fibers and 10 kilohertz
auditory nerve fibers
to this type of stimulus.
And obviously, the
1 kilohertz fibers
are going to be very active.
During portions
of this utterance,
for example, there's
a lot of 1 kilohertz
in this "oh" second
formant here.
So the 1 kilohertz fiber's going
to respond like crazy there.
In the vowel "ah," there's a
big 1 kilohertz band there.
The 1 kilohertz fiber is
going to respond a lot there.
It's not going to
respond here or here.
But it's going to respond a lot
at the end of the "out" sound.
OK.
The 10 kilohertz fiber is
kind of out of luck, right?
Its way up here.
It's off the axis.
But notice the tail of
this 10 kilohertz fiber.
If I had drawn it a
little bit further
it would be extending
past 1 kilohertz.
So it's certainly going to
respond, right, in here,
as long as the sound
level is high enough.
If you keep the sound level
of this utterance low,
down here, then the frequency
is obviously down here.
That 10 kilohertz fiber
is not going to respond.
But if you boost the
sound level, such
that you're in the tail
of the tuning curve,
this 10 kilohertz CF fiber
is going to start to respond.
For example, response to these
frequencies here, this 4, 5,
and 6 kilohertz.
Maybe the 7
kilohertz can respond
to things like the consonants,
if the sound level is high
enough so that it's
within its response areas.
So there's clear CF processing
of this type of speech signal
at the auditory nerve and
in the cochlear nucleus.
There's also phase locking.
For example, these
lower frequencies
are within the frequency
range where there's really
good phase locking for
the auditory nerve.
Remember, phase locking
falls off above 1 kilohertz.
And by about 3
kilohertz, there's
not much phase locking at all.
But many of these voiced,
or vowel, segments
are going to have
low frequencies.
And they're going to
be good phase locking
in the auditory nerve
or cochlear nucleus.
So that's just sort of a review.
Think about the auditory
nerve response to these speech
signals because clearly,
the auditory nerve
is going to respond
very nicely, in terms
of what its CFs tell it to.
Now, there's been a lot
of interesting work.
Of course, I don't have time to
get into much speech processing
and language representation.
But I just wanted to
show you some things that
relate quite nicely to what
we've just gone through
for echolocation.
Here are some synthesized
speech stimuli.
OK.
And you can do this very
nicely on your computer.
This is a spectrogram of
the synthesized sound.
Frequency is on the
y-axis and time,
in this case in milliseconds,
the very quick stimulus
is on the x-axis.
And there are several
harmonics, very much
like we had for the CF
echolocating bat sound.
And there's some regions
of constant frequency.
And there are
clearly some regions
of frequency modulation, very
much like the bat echolocating
signal that we just went over.
Except that now the
modulated part of the signal
is in the front
instead of at the back
like it was for the bat.
And so right here,
on the third formant,
is a very interesting transition
that's not shown in black.
It's shown in white.
Because in the work of Liberman
and Mattingly from the 1980s,
they studied this so-called
formant transition.
So the format here
is the vowel "ah."
And you have these three
formants, 1, 2, and 3.
And the transition
leading up into that
is either the consonant
D or the consonant G.
It's when it's coming down.
It's the combination "da."
but when this third formant
transition is instead going
up, it's the consonant "gah."
completely different speech
sound, "da" versus "gah."
No one would ever mistake them.
Right.
And so what Liberman and
Mattingly did was they
varied this transition
into the third formant.
Instead of just having one
like that, or one like this,
they sloped it any
number of degrees.
All right.
And when it goes, I think
when it's falling, it's "da."
And when it's rising, it's
"gah" if I'm not mistaken.
So what would you expect if
it was right in the middle?
Well, you could expect anything.
But actually, the
observation is,
as you move this
formant transition over,
subjects do not report
something that's
in between "gah" and "da."
Instead, all of a
sudden, they quickly
shift from "gah" to "da."
All of a sudden.
And there's a very sharp
boundary in the shift.
And the subjects never report
something that's intermediate.
So this is an example of
putting the speech sound, which
can be modulating continuously,
into two sharply defined
perceptual categories.
Either "gah" or either "da."
But nothing in between.
No gradual slope in between.
It's just one or the other.
This gave rise to the idea
of categorical perception
of speech sounds.
The other thing they could
do is do things like this.
Present the black stimuli to
one ear and the white stimuli
to the other ear.
And you get the perception,
then, of a speech sound.
If you don't present any
formant transition at all,
what would you expect to happen?
Well, what actually happens is
you do hear something ambiguous
if there's actually no
formant transition at all.
If there's a formant
transition, in one ear
and the rest of the
sound to the other ear,
you hear the complete
speech sound.
If you just present this formant
transition and nothing else,
you just hear a little
chirp, a little speech sound.
But you add that to
the rest, and you
get an unambiguous or
categorical "da" or "gah."
OK.
These are beautiful
series of experiments
by Alvin Liberman in the 1980s.
Now, in cortex, the
interesting question,
then, if you pull an
analogy between bat signals
and human signals,
we've had spectrograms
from the two which are
not that much different.
The question is, do we
have specialized neurons
in our cortices that are
sensitive to specific features
of those signals?
For example, features are things
like whether these two formants
are close together,
whether there's
a formant sweep going
down or going up.
Do we have specific,
if you will,
feature detectors
in the human cortex?
We don't know that.
What we do know
clearly is that there
are areas that are very
selective for language
and speech stimuli in
the cortex of humans.
So in the cortex
of humans, we've
talked about there
being a primary auditory
cortex in the
temporal lobe here.
And we had the little
model that showed you
that there was a Heschl's gyrus.
And that is the site of
primary auditory cortex, or A1,
in humans.
All around that region,
an area that's sometimes
called perisylvian cortex.
And it gets its name from
this big sylvian fissure,
if you will, that divides
the temporal lobe down here
from the rest of the brain,
especially the parietal lobe.
All around this
perisylvian cortex
is associated with
language processing.
And how do we know that?
Well, of course,
imaging studies.
But in the beginning,
the early pathologists
like Broca and Wernicke,
who studied patients
who had lesions in the
cortex, mostly from strokes.
But sometimes from
other injuries.
It showed that lesions in
this region of the brain
left patients with deficits
in language processing,
especially with a
deficit called aphasia.
OK?
Disorders of comprehending
or producing spoken language
are known as aphasia.
And these aphasias are
often classified into types.
If you're a neurology resident,
or you do your medical rotation
in neurology, you
will see patients
with so-called Broca's aphasia.
And this, originally, was
brought to light by Broca.
We saw such patients
with lesions
in this part of the brain.
That's come to be
known as Broca's area.
That's part of the
frontal cortex, the lower
frontal cortex,
near motor areas.
And the clinical manifestation
is a major disturbance
in speech production, with
sparse or halting speech.
It's often misarticulated,
missing function words,
and parts of words.
So this is clearly a problem
with producing speech.
Sometimes this is
called motor aphasia.
Wernicke is another
early physician
who saw patients with
damaged cortices.
He saw some of them with
damage to this region,
in the caudal temporal lobe
and associated parietal lobe.
It's an area which has become
known as Wernicke's area.
And here, the
clinical manifestation
is completely different.
In this case, the production
of speech is fine.
But it's a major disturbance
in auditory comprehension.
OK.
So you ask the patient something
and they cannot understand you.
But they have fluent
speech production.
It's fluent speech
with maybe disturbances
of the sounds and
structures of the words.
But the major deficit is in
the auditory comprehension,
language comprehension.
So the question,
then, has always been,
is this Broca's
area the motor area
for production of
speech and language?
And is this Wernicke's
area the area
for comprehension of speech?
And clearly, this is a
very simplistic idea,
in what would be called
the localizational idea.
I'm not sure if
that word is here.
But if you're a so-called
localization proponent,
you would say each
little part of the cortex
has its own function.
And they do that independently
of all the other areas.
So the Broca's area is
involved in producing speech.
And Wernicke's area is
responsible for comprehending
speech.
And this is clearly
from imaging studies
that we know now is a very
simplistic view, and probably
an incorrect view.
It's more likely this
whole of perisylvian cortex
contributes to
language processing.
And so people who
subscribe to that theory
would be called holistic.
They'd have the holistic
view of processing in cortex.
And we'll go over the imaging
studies in just a minute.
One thing I want
to make sure to say
is that language processing is
clearly a cortical phenomenon.
That is, if you have
injury to the cortex
in these specific areas,
you're likely to have aphasia.
If you have injuries to the
brain stem, to the thalamus,
you are much less likely to
have any kind of aphasia.
So clearly, the
cortex is the place
where language is processed.
Another thing about cortex
and language processing
is that it's usually lateralized
into one hemisphere or another,
OK?
So if you're right handed,
usually your language
is processed in your
opposite hemifield,
in the left cortical area.
And so how is that known?
Well, if you have a stroke
patient whose right handed,
they have a lesion
in the left cortex.
They show up with aphasia.
If they have a lesion
in the right cortex,
there's minimal effect on
their language functions.
Another way is by the
so-called Wada test.
So people who are getting ready
to have cortical neurosurgery--
so why would you ever want to
have cortical neurosurgery?
Anybody?
So another big disease in the
cortex is epilepsy, right?
Epilepsy is uncontrolled
activity, usually starting
in the cortex.
Of course, the first line
of attack is by medication.
But some epileptic
patients have epilepsy
that is not controlled
by medication.
And they have seizures
every half hour.
And it's pretty
much intractable.
So the last line of attack,
then, by the neurosurgeons
is to try to go into the cortex
and find the part of the cortex
where the epileptic
focus begins.
And then they'd lesion that.
And this is a
successful treatment.
But if the surgeon goes in and
lesions part of the language
areas, you have a patient
that wakes up as an aphasic.
That's not a happy patient.
So the surgeons do lots of
tests before such surgery.
And one is to try to figure out
which hemisphere is processing
the language.
So they do the Wada test.
Has anybody heard
of the Wada test?
OK.
They take the patient, of
course, and-- if they're smart
and they plan ahead,
the patient is seated.
OK?
And they have a carotid
artery on the left side,
and a carotid artery
on the right side.
And into the carotid
artery is injected
a quick acting
barbiturate anesthetic.
On one side, that carotid
artery feeds one hemisphere
of the cortex and not the other.
So the patient is seated
because the patient
is likely to slump
because they're
going to have some
motor problems.
And the patient might fall
over if they were standing up.
But in the test, the
patient is supposed
to recite from reading
or from memory.
And the anesthetic is injected.
And as soon as that anesthetic
hits the hemisphere that's
processing language, the
patient stops reciting.
That's if they injected
on the correct side.
If they injected
on the other side,
the patient keeps
reading, keeps reciting.
So that's the Wada test.
Language function is
mostly in one hemisphere
in right handed individuals
In left handers,
things are a little
bit different.
Left handed
individuals sometimes
have the opposite
hemispheric dominance.
Sometimes they have
language function
distributed bilaterally.
Sometimes they have
language function
in the same side as
their handedness.
OK.
But for this, I'm talking
about right handers, OK?
Here's some very
interesting work
looking at the language
areas in people.
In postmortem, material has
been done by Al Galaburda.
So he's at Beth Israel
Deaconess Hospital now.
And he looked at
the left hemisphere
and the right hemispheres.
And he looked at the very,
of course, closely associated
language areas,
especially right near A1.
And so here is-- you can't see
them on a side view like this--
but if you cut off the top of
the cortex, which you can do.
This is postmortem material.
You look down on the superior
surface of the temporal lobe,
you see these views here.
And the area that's just caudal
to the primary auditory cortex
is called the plenum temporally.
And there are clearly some
left-right asymmetries
in that region of the brain
that almost certainly relate
to language processing
in that area.
OK?
So there are
anatomical asymmetries
in the perisylvian regions.
And so this is the first
time in our course,
now, where right and left
makes a big difference.
All along, we said
it doesn't matter
if we simulated the right
ear or the left ear.
And here, clearly, there
is a dominant hemisphere
for language.
Now finally,
imaging studies have
shown us a great deal about
the cortical processing
of language.
And here's data from a pet
study, in which the subjects
are listening to
language stimuli.
And these happen to be
French speaking subjects.
So the last condition
is a story in French.
And obviously, the subjects
understood the story.
They could tell you
what was going on.
And these are, by the way,
right handed subjects.
And here's the imaging of the
areas in the left hemisphere,
which would be expected to
be the dominant hemisphere
for language.
And this is in the
other hemisphere,
which shows a lot
less activation.
The activation in the areas
where the subjects were
listening to language
they understood
is the superior temporal
area, superior temporal gyrus.
That's including the temporal
pole here, in purple.
You can't see the
yellow very well.
But believe there's a
lot of activation here.
This blue area, labeled
IFG inferior frontal gyrus,
this is Broca's area.
And why does it light up
if Broca's area is only
a motor area?
It's clearly involved
in motor functions.
But here is imaging results from
subjects just listening, not
producing language, where
Broca's area lights up.
It's activated on
the dominant side,
just in the listening task.
Contrast that to when the
subjects were listening
to a story in a language
that they did not understand,
this language is called Tamil.
And none of the
subjects could speak it.
There's hardly any
activation in the original.
There's a little bit
of yellow activation
near the primary
auditory cortex.
It's pretty symmetric,
left to right.
And that's just
what you'd expect
if you were, for example,
given pure tones or noise.
This is a nice control because,
presumably, this language
has about the same
frequency content.
And other factors are fairly
similar between these two
languages.
The one difference
is the subjects
were not perceptually aware
of what they were learning
about in the story, in the
case of the unfamiliar.
These intermediate
conditions, some
of them having pseudo words
and anomalous sentences,
didn't light up the language
areas to a great degree.
But listening to a list, in this
case, of French words-- which
the subjects were familiar
to-- again, showed activation.
I'll point out to
you in Broca's area
in the dominant hemisphere, in
these right handed subjects.
So again, clearly,
just a listening task
can light up Broca's area.
And so that is a
very clear example.
I'll show you that
these so-called motor
areas, like Broca's
area, are involved
in listening and cortex
processing of language stimuli.
It's not just involved in
motor production of speech,
even though what we call
clinically Broca's aphasia
has a major disturbance
in speech production.
OK.
And one final thing
to leave you with.
Broca's area tends to
light up, in this case,
in fairly simple stimuli.
But it tends to light
up in other studies,
like in cases where
the substances have
difficult grammar
or complex meaning.
And so the subjects,
you can imagine,
are really listening
hard and trying
to figure out the meaning
of a sentence that
has a complicated grammar.
I think we've all
written such senses.
We've all tried to read
them from other writers.
And it takes a lot of brain
power, then, to decode that,
and figure out the meaning.
And maybe that's
what happens here.
Broca's area's called
in when the task gets
more difficult than just
a simple list of words.
In this case, it lit up.
And in other studies, it's
clearly showing more activation
when the task gets
more difficult.
OK.
So we're out of time.
I can take a question or two.
And just a reminder,
class meets at Mass.
Eye and Ear on Wednesday
for the lab tour.
So I'll see you over there.